this video shows the borders of
populations of each country in Europe
for every year since 400 BC before
Christ I'm just going to let that run
while I'm delivering this this is
something that has that has gone on
essentially since the beginning of time
and again this is only from just before
you know was it 400 BC okay um if you're
unfamiliar with human beings as a
species uh we're very similar to
chimpanzees in the sense and in the
regard that we like conflict and that we
form tribes and that we wage war uh
chimpanzees are one of the only other uh
primates out there and make no mistake
we're just Advanced versions of these
primates that figured out microphones
and cameras and lighting and you know
how to stream [__] on the internet but
we're very very similar genetically we
share like 98% of our DNA with our
primate cousins two panies are very
similar they'll they'll go out and
they'll wage war against other tribes
they'll actually kill kill other chimps
they're they're vicious like um when you
dive into the rabbit hole of of these
primates they'll rip off the genitalia
of their competition okay they will do
some Savage things and humans really
aren't that different uh we're very
similar in the sense and in the regard
that we've we've always waged War we've
always tried to dominate we've always
tried to run the world and I'm just
going to pause it here for a sec on this
map and actually go full screen so I'm
listening to this audio book right now
called Cesar's
Legions via a recommendation of 50
Shades of Green who's one of the
generals on my Saturday shows that I
populate from time to time and this is
the Roman Empire as it stands right now
population 42 million throughout Europe
uh just sort of give you an idea okay
just a little bit of an idea but hey
that was a large empire and there's been
the Ottoman Empire the British Empire
like there's been a lot of Empires Greek
Empire you know prior to that very very
interesting read right so I mean the
point that I'm making here is this stuff
has always again happened throughout
history and will always continue to
happen into the future everybody that's
always suing for peace Oh we must you
know all we need is love love all this
stuff right like all we need is love and
that's going to solve everything don't
you think they've tried that for the
last uh you know thousand odd years
right or sorry 2400 years you know as
this map runs itself it's in the year
169 right now after death
ad they've tried that and never worked
it's never worked in the past I'm going
to tell you right now it's never going
to work in the future um the difference
between this time and
today is the people living in Africa and
Japan and China and all those other
regions of the world they didn't care
about what was happening in Europe they
didn't care how the borders changed they
didn't care how leadership changed they
didn't care about the crown or royalty
they didn't care about any of that stuff
because they didn't get sucked into it
nobody was trying to get them to care
today they try to get you to care about
there's a really really good essay uh
Jack Donovan's written just called I
don't care I'm not going to read it it's
a long essay you can go look it up on
the internet but essentially you know
there they they try to suck you in and
steal your FS as I talk about in the
chapter in my book about managing your
FS which is essentially managing your
energy they try to steal it from you
today and get you to care about random
things and I understand war is something
that's devastating and people die and it
it destroys infrastructure and and
children and women and all that sort of
stuff hurt and Men die and and suffer in
these conflicts I get it but this is who
we
are surrendering to who we are as a
species and what we're all about and how
we operate and how we navigate the world
and how we think and how we hold
ourselves out ain't going to change it's
hard wired into our DNA we're always
going to be doing stuff like this we're
borders will always change leadership
will change people will get hurt along
the way infrastructure will get
destroyed land will get you know
re-evaluated reclaimed this is this is
how it goes it's always gone that way
this is why I'm showing you this video
for this reference it's at one and a
half time
still so with that being said and it's
not just things like
War they want you to care about oh we
didn't use the right pronouns or they
want you to care about oh this
marginalized group out there right now
and in many cases it's not even a
marginalized group it's it's like people
that have a victim mindset or they want
to be victims in the world it's
interesting man like you know we live in
a time now where it's been popularized
to be a victim it's it's actually
encourage you know the victim mindset is
encourag oh poor me oh woes of me uh if
you want a good example of how
we've we've trained women now how toxic
feminism has trained women as an example
to be a victim go watch last week's
ladies night and watch a couple of
ladies on there when we're talking about
some of the problems that they're
experiencing why they're not getting
good results in life why they can't
attract the guys that they're looking
for and then it turns into oh well rich
is mean and you're not talking nicely to
me sort of thing and I feel like a
victim and I just feel like and you hear
that I feel like and get the idea I mean
those that have watched it understand
exactly what I'm saying but this is what
we're training people to do we're
training people to care about stuff that
shouldn't matter why should I care if
some this is straight out of Jack's
essay why should I care if some gal
who's walking in New York city named
shashana who gets catall by them by some
guy is now in the news or in the 10
o'clock news or in the Twitter feed or
the trending topic because how it makes
them feel why do we need to care about
that
you know this perimeter that we draw as
the unplugged Alphas do is separating us
from them we're supposed to care about
us we're supposed to care about our
family our kids the people on the inside
the people that we love people that we
care about the people that are part of
our tribe the ones that we've defined
and then there's always going to be an
outside if you follow me on Twitter
you'll notice that I use the US versus
them descriptor it's you know it's a
placeholder because that exists it's
always exist existed that's why it's uh
you know Russia versus Ukraine that's
why it's Israel versus Palestine that's
why it's China versus Taiwan that's why
you can go right down the list you know
you can go throughout history as this
map is running here as it demonstrates
we're at 1577 right now you see the
Ottoman Empire well where's the Roman
Empire it's completely destroyed you see
the Russian Empire that's developing
there as well these things are moving
targets they keep moving right and me
caring or you caring or anybody else
caring about that I am not going to have
any impact on that it's not going to
change anything it's not going to change
the outcome it's let them sus it out on
the RO let them figure it out right
there are certain
scenarios in history and in that prior
map with the dots where you'll see uh
atrocities you know where certain
peoples are victimized then there might
be some
need to get involved but why do we
always have to police everything all the
time in the world you know there's there
there's there's far too much
governance and need to suck us into care
about stuff that does like the whole
scamdemic thing you know the beer buug
right they wanted to suck the world into
this notion and and they were very
successful for the most part with a vast
majority of the population standing on
your dots wearing your mask get your jab
get your eighth jab get your 17th jab
very successful and convincing and that
that exercise I think was a test you
know to see how society would respond
you know you can call it whatever you
want you can call it a war game you can
call it anything you want but I think
that it was a test let me just take that
out over
there but you understand what I'm saying
here right like why do we need to care
why do we need to get sucked into to to
things that don't influence my
day-to-day here here my family things
that I care about within the inner
perimeter right even if you're Russian
like I have a good friend of mine he's
Russian Ukrainian Jew
okay is he Russian no is he ukan no is
he Jew he actually wears a cross right
that was his origin you ask him about
what's going on over there and he's like
it's [__] it's got nothing to do with
Ukraine got nothing to do with Russia
it's all about the West trying to
influence what's going on with those
borders and what happens in that area
and
destabilize right I think for the vast
majority of these things that they want
us to suck in and get and and dispense
FS for and care about don't really need
it are there scenarios and situations
where it's required maybe but the vast
majority of them it's not needed they
want to suck you in want to distract you
I want to control you I want you to
think about them over and over again
proxy wars conflict ing about stuff oh
we didn't use the right pronouns oh my
God this guy is this guy we have to care
about this this gender this race this
made up uh alphabet sup like why why do
we really is it utterly necessary how
does it improve your life how does that
make you your own mental point of origin
with where you're going and the sort of
life that you're want it's it's a
distraction it's a distraction from the
fact that you're paying taxes it's a
distraction from the fact that you're
probably stuck and a dead end j o and
they want you just over broke paycheck
to paycheck it's a distraction from the
interest rates going through the roof do
you really need to care about all these
things that they're trying to suck you
into again it goes back to the chapter
in my book manage your
FS manage your
FS if you don't understand the concept
get the concept through your head stop
getting distracted stop dispensing them
in areas that you want I I talk about a
prime example in the book about road
rage you know um people will cut you off
they'll not use the signal they'll cut
in front of you oh you get mad you start
honking your horn give him the finger in
the
mirr I've seen people do this where they
just get pissed off and it's
like sometimes they get pissed off
because you just put yourself in line
and maybe you got a little too close to
their bumper they get pissed off because
they think they own parts of the road
right sometimes it's them doing it to
you but why like why get mad why what is
what is the benefit of dispensing your
energy for something that is not worthy
of that what is the benefit of
dispensing your energy for caring about
agendas and causes that don't matter I
mean like I get it I get it there's
there's gullible and persuadable people
out there I think the vast majority of
people want to be ruled they want a
ruler I think we know this human beings
like being ruled throughout history
anyway we like being ruled oh 3,000
years ago Lord Almighty King of the
realm I will give you taxes and pay you
you know my my dues at least they got
something in return back then you know
they had uh Army to defend them you know
like they like there was a little bit of
benefit to them then but there was no
interference in their life there was no
you have to use this pronoun or you have
to put this flat up or celebrate this uh
month of the year for this pretend
marginalized group or something like
that you see what I'm saying right I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out